where would you put hypocracy in the
realm of things with humans versus
animals disastrously human you know not
only are we capable of coming up with
theologies ideologies not only are we
capable in every culture of coming up
with strictures on behavior that are
framed ethically but we are come up with
the means to personally evade it over
and over and in lots of ways you know
the really scary individuals for this
planet are not the ones who say
everybody says X is a criminal thing to
do but I disagree what's really scary is
the person who says everybody's as X is
a criminal thing and I agree but here's
why I'm a special case right now and
what humans are magnificent at is
setting up sets of rules and then
deciding why you are justified and being
freed from them so it is one of the more
corrosive spin-offs of sort of our
systems of ethical behavior the notion
that it doesn't count with me
when I did it it means something
different because it's a separate
compartment